So, Product Hunt has been blowing up.
What do you think made them so
successful?
>> So, Product Hunt is an interesting
story because my contributing author
on the book is a guy by
the name of Ryan Hoover,
who was working a job at
a startup that he was okay with.
He wasn't super happy about.
But Ryan emailed me one day and said,
hey, I've been reading your articles on
TechCrunch, and
I like this consumer psychology stuff.
How can I help you?
So we got together for
lunch one day, and I said, look,
I've got all these articles.
I've been thinking about putting
them together in a book.
Do you think you could kind of help
me make them into this cohesive book,
as opposed to a bunch
disparate articles?
And he did.
We worked on it for several months, and
he did a fantastic job.
I really enjoyed working with him.
Well, there's nobody who understand
the hook model second to me
better than Ryan.
And the next thing that Ryan did
after we worked on this book
was to start Product Hunt.
And he designed Product Hunt from
the get-go with the hook model in mind.
Now the company is doing
phenomenally well.
I'm lucky enough to be an investor.
So full disclosure, I happen to
be a fan for a number of reasons.
But, yeah, the app is doing incredibly
well because it was designed with this
hook at the early days
of the product design.
And of course, Ryan and his team
get 110% of the credit for this.
I have the easy part of just
talking about the theory,
but they had to actually implement it.
But I think they saved
themselves a lot of time and
found the right thing
sooner by using the model.
>> And now I as a new
entrepreneur can do the same?
>> Right, so again,
I am a little biased here.
But I think it starts by taking
some time to figure out your hook.
Before you've laid down any code,
before you've done any wire frames, just
to think about what the core experience
is that you want to turn into a habit.
And then ask yourself, do you have the
fundamental characteristics of a habit
forming technology, by number one, have
you identified the internal trigger?
Do you know your users' itch?
Number two,
what's the external trigger that
gives the user some piece of
information to do the intended action?
Number three,
what's the intended behavior, and
how can it be made as
simple as possible?
Number four, the variable reward is how
are you giving the user what they want,
scratching their itch, and yet
leaving them wanting more.
And then finally, the investment phase,
the fifth question,
is what's the bit of work that the user
does to prompt the next action,
to load the next trigger, and
to store value in the product.
And if you can answer
those five questions, and
you have this core hook in your mind,
you can design accordingly.
And it becomes much easier to
build the right thing sooner.
>> Can I use the same model
on existing products?
>> Sure.
So,
it's a little bit more
difficult because as you know,
once you've built a product,
it's kind of hard to change it, right?
You've done all the architecting.
People have worked
hundreds of hours on it.
It's harder to change and so,
what oftentimes I see people doing is
I'll get emails from an entrepreneur or
a product manager.
And they'll say to me look, we've been
struggling with this product, and
until we read your book, we couldn't
figure out why people weren't using it.
Right, we put so
much effort into building it, and
we didn't know what was going on.
A few customers were telling
us they really liked it,
but even they weren't using it.
So then the book can become a diagnostic
tool where you can figure out oh,
this is why people aren't coming back.
We haven't identified
the right internal trigger.
The external trigger isn't effective.
The action is too difficult.
The reward isn't very rewarding.
Or we're not asking people for
the investment at the right time.
So then it becomes a diagnostic tool,
and
then you can of course
correct from there.
>> So what hooks does Product Hunt have?
>> Sure, so
I think Product Hunt has a great hook.
It's something that people
use on a daily basis.
I think their hook is very reliant
on this external trigger of
getting an email.
So you get this daily email from
Product Hunt that says hey,
here's the latest and
greatest in technology products.
The action then is to open the email and
to reveal the variable reward.
Now, the variable reward is this
uncertainty about, well what is it?
What is the latest and greatest, right?
You're looking through all these various
products to see one that might be
interesting to you.
You click on one of those products.
If you go to the Product Hunt discussion
page, there's all these discussions
happening about people talking with
the founders of these products.
There's this great community
formed around these products.
And the more you interact with
that community by commenting,
by sharing things to that community,
by creating collections,
all of these things load
the next trigger and store value.
So the next time it won't be
your daily digest anymore.
Now it'll be an email from oh, this is
your friend who you trust, who just
posted something to Product Hunt
prompting you to come back again, right?
That's a piece of information
that you've given the company
that can now send you through that
four steps of the hook once again.
The more you use the product, and
this is where I think investors think
the company can grow
outside of just technology,
is that it learns your tastes.
It learns what you're into.
And so hopefully over time that hook
expands into all different kinds
of interesting industry areas.
>> So understanding me and
giving me more relevant results.
>> Right, exactly.
That's part of this investment phase.